last time I trusted someone I lost
enough oh you're not around it's hard to
explain I think I had a life here I see
flashes but I can't tell if it's real
hey everybody its charlie we got a whole
bunch of new Captain Marvel to break
down they dropped a new promo for her
special comic book armor ben mendelsohn
who plays Talos the scroll leader did a
big preview for the scroll storyline and
his character in Marvel just released a
really special feature that Kevin Feige
did about his final meeting with Stan
Lee that I'll talk about the end of the
video just because it's really touching
if you're new to the channel we're also
doing an IMAX ticket giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a Marvel related comment on
the video so just starting with her
comic book armor we get much more
accurate up to date designs for what
it's going to look like towards the end
of the film this is obviously just a
modification of her Kree green star
force uniform although technically all
the people in the Kree military wear
green uniforms like this they probably
just embellished this a little bit to
make it quote-unquote Star Force because
there's a giant star in the middle of
her chest there but as you'll see with
the scroll storyline and the whole idea
that they're being misled about what's
really going on scrolls masquerading
lied to Nick Fury about what's going on
same thing happening with Captain Marvel
in her storyline
once she reassert sir true identity she
makes this costume for herself so that's
why you see it towards the end of the
trailer because that's happening towards
the end of the movie after she found out
about all the [ __ ] that they've been
trying to pull on her this promo is a
much better example of what she looks
like in her full armor with the helmet
activated it also gives you a much
better look at what she looks like with
the mohawk people were really sure how
they were gonna handle that it could
have been silly if they did it the wrong
way but I think the way they explained
it during the trailer is actually pretty
ingenious
so you see them flying through space
when she's still a member of Star Force
they're on some mission during the movie
and you can see the Mohawk sort of
flipping around after she activates her
helmet and it's the exact same way that
Black Panthers helmet works Iron Man's -
but they did a better job of actually
explaining it during the Black Panther
movie when Sheree is giving T'Challa his
brand new costume Exhibit A by design
ootek old functional but old people are
shooting at me wait let me put on my
helmet enough this one
now tell it to go the entire suit sits
within the teeth so during that scene
she explains to him that the armor
itself is coated to him with a neural
interface so all he has to do is think
helmet on in the helmet will engage it's
the same deal with Captain Marvel's
armor albeit with a Kree version of that
technology so obviously they're a very
advanced spacefaring race they do not
have vibranium so I still think that
Black Panther could probably make a
better version of this costume for her
but she has technology that's way more
advanced than what we have on planet
Earth
save for people like Black Panther Iron
Man and probably Thor Thor only makes it
seem like he's really dumb he actually
does understand how Asgardian technology
works but he's not an engineer so he
could probably fix some of their
technology but if a rocket wanted a
really cool Asgardian weapon then he
would just take him back to eatery and
have each remake something for him so
between everyone's technology and their
relative natural power levels it all
kind of balances out a little bit with
Captain Marvel being on the more
powerful end of the spectrum up there
with Thor with Stormbreaker the closest
we see her getting to binary form is
right towards the end of the trailer and
even that probably isn't full binary
form I think they're gonna save a little
something for Avengers 4 there been a
lot of reports about shots of her
showing up in the trailer punching
Thanos just to show how powerful she is
just because we haven't got her a movie
yet I'm not expecting a ton of her in
that first Avengers teaser trailer maybe
just a logo shot or something from her
costume to let you know that she's in
the film because weirdly enough I still
see a lot of questions on videos that
I'll post asking whether or not she's in
the movie like yes of course
Captain Marvel is a big part of Avengers
4 moving on to Ben Mendelsohn's scroll
preview though so his character Talos is
the leader of their little elite squad
that's trying to infiltrate earth so
there's a couple of different plots
going on during the movie the a plot is
the Scrolls infiltrating earth the B
plot is Captain Marvel rediscovering who
she is depending on how you look at it
some people will view that more as the
main story but Technic
the whole premise of the film is that
there are Scrolls on planet Earth and
that's the thing that brings her back in
how she starts to rediscover who she is
because she's often starforce at the
beginning of the movie the scroll story
is more of a meta fake-out plot about a
fake plot he's Nick Fury's supervisor in
shield circa 1995 mid 90s but it's not
like he went up through the ranks at
shield he just infiltrated them by
taking down Nick Fury's pre-existing
supervisor that looked like Ben
Mendelsohn he says one of the beauties
of his character is that he gets to have
scenes with everyone and obviously
because he can masquerade as anyone it's
not just ben mendelsohn that Talos will
be looking like people have been seeing
all those shots of young Coulson saying
you know it's so great to see clark
gregg back in the movies but as cool as
that is double fake-out wouldn't it also
be cool to see him be a scroll for at
least a little while during the film so
you wind up with a situation where Clark
Gregg plays a couple different versions
of himself you can do the same thing
with Nick Fury - although most of the
film is from his perspective and from
Captain Marvel's perspective the way
they described this version of Nick Fury
is that he's a 40-something who's just
getting ready to retire to take a normal
job but he's getting tired of it he has
that voice over during the trailer truth
be told I was getting ready to hang it
all up until you showed up on my door so
even though the Skrull Empire does have
Grand Designs to take over planet Earth
save for the three Infinity stones that
are currently there as the mid-1990s you
have the space stone and the tesseract
that shield already has possession of as
of the events of this film you have the
aether which is still sort of buried
between dimensions within the earth then
you have the eye of agamotto the time
stone which is at the sanctum so you
just have to remember that even though
Infinity stones aren't a big part of the
plot during this movie they're still
there it's still a very big deal in the
grand scheme of things they'll probably
be some Easter egg scene referencing all
that stuff because Nick Fury is still
relatively mid-level he probably doesn't
learn that shield has the tesseract
until he becomes director much later in
the timeline but while this Captain
Marvel stuff is going on they still have
their dark energy research going on in
the background
they've been researching all that stuff
at the base that they blow up at the
beginning of the Avengers movie for a
long time this was actually built
relatively soon after Howard Stark died
but Howard stark himself pioneered a lot
of the early
search on the tesseract the beauty of
Talos infiltrating shield though is that
he can actually use them against Captain
Marvel all he has to do is tell his
underling Nick Fury and baby Coulson
who's fresh off the book like a brand
new redshirt SHIELD agent that there's a
dangerous space alien that's come into
Earth's orbit that means to do us harm
bring her in capture her so we can
interrogate her obviously as a ruse so
that he Talos and the other scrolls can
interrogate her and find out how to take
down the crease star force that are
after them they did shoot a Stan Lee
cameo for the movie I have no idea what
it's going to be he shot cameos for the
three upcoming big live-action Marvel
movies I'm expecting him to get a cameo
during spider-man into the spider-verse
as well too in some animated form if I
also joked that when they were on set
working on movies that he would always
try to add more lines he would always
joke but not really joke about wanting
more lines although he understood why we
couldn't the ant-man the wasp actually
does have a pretty long reel of him
trying a bunch of different takes of
that cameo this is a clip from that know
my sandwich was in there well at least
now I'll be able to park in San
Francisco oh man I just stole his car so
which is a really touching remembrance
from Kevin Feige of his final
interaction with Stan Lee it's always
fun to hear those stories just because
Stan Lee is so amazing and all of them
but what'll happen is is there's a bunch
of Marvel stuff coming up I know
everybody wants to know when the
Avengers 4 trailer is gonna drop if I
hear any rumors about it I will totally
do a video no worries click here to
watch Hugh Jackman talk about Deadpool
and Avengers crossover and click here
for my non-spoiler review of spider-man
into the spider burst
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]